Chứ khi thăm sự misborn bảo ngọt măng lĩnh trẻ của mình sẽ quảng ninh.
Chứ khi bất lình đấu trưởng misborn, bảo ngọt không chỉ tập luyện các quốc hay kiện năng đứng sự,
phố trọng đồng hành cùng hai bốn bởi Xpera Stanker Xan Đến với cả em học sinh cùng cao tại trường tiêu học khoảng sinh hai,
sát đường hoa tình quảng ninh, nhiều gia đình nơi đây còn sống dựa vào sinh, yet của bạn lấy tiền cho còn đón học phí.
Con chỉ ước được đi học để xong này thác nhèu, một em nhỏ chia sẻ với vọng ngọt,
khiến cô lặng người trước các tọng sản sị nhưng đánh y lực của chẻ thơ, ở tối thác em đáng xa là mưa những giúp mơ tối thơ,
nhưng với nhiều em ước mơ sản đơn nhất là được đi học để thác nhèu.
Hành trình này được thực hiện trong quân khổ chương trị giáo hắn, chuyển yêu thương xo hai bốn bởi Xpera khởi sướng.
Chương trình không chỉ chàng những phần học bộ cho các em học sinh học rồi, mình có hoàn cạnh khó khăn mà còn chàng bị dụng của học tập.
A ổn đồng vụ, mái chiếu và màn chiếu, suất em có điều kiện học tập tốt hơn.
Mỗi món qua, mỗi số học bộ không chỉ là bất chất mà có lại sáng hiểu vào,
là ngắn được chuyển đúng lúc để tiếp theo độ lực cho các em tiếp tục đến chương.
Chia xè về chuyển đi, bảo ngọt nói, những ngày cũng chỉ trình dào ngắn chuyển yêu thương đến với khoảng nên.
Điều động lại nhiều nhất trong lòng tôi chính là tiếng cửa của những em nhỏ.
Sữa những khó khăn các em vẫn cửa y vẫn mơ ước, tại vẫn tin vào một ngày mai khác.
Chính những lụ cửa ý là mình hiểu rằng, đôi khi chỉ cần một chút yêu thương được chuyển đến kịp lúc, nắng sẽ đủ để xe ấm trái tin các em.
Chương trình dào ngắn chuyển yêu thương gia đời từ năm 2020.
Tập trung hỗ trợ trẻ em phùng cao và phùng bên dưới trên khóc cả nước với mỗi hình trình.
Hãy bốn với Express không chỉ vẫn chuyển hàng hoá mà còn mang theo hiểu vào,
liêm tin vào yêu thương đến những phùng rất còn nhiều khó khăn.